the theater industry is going to need a
lot more than a jug of Tolkien brain
juice to gain in mortality and Avatar
2's opening numbers aren't turning out
to be the magic sauce James Cameron
hoped for the opening of Avatar the way
of water is nothing to bulk at with a
long end development sequel raking in
more than 400 million dollars worldwide
in its opening weekend for Box Office
Mojo the numbers however fell below
projections some of which had the movie
topping 500 million dollars globally the
reason this difference matters more in
2022 is that the box office is still
trying to make a full comeback after the
shutdowns that stemmed from the covid-19
pandemic to achieve this goal the U.S
box office is relying on massive
Blockbusters like Avatar the way of
water as more and more films like
Halloween ends are released directly to
streaming but the truth is what we
really need to focus on is getting back
to theaters that said must-see
theatrical experiences that promise to
push visual boundaries are still
managing to find a place at the box
office for instance top gun Maverick
stands as a Year's biggest runaway
success pulling in nearly 1.5 billion
dollars worldwide so as far as the
numbers stand 2022 proved that audiences
are ready to return to Cinemas however
2022's domestic Financial receipts are
nearly 34 percent lower than 2019's
earnings meaning that the box office
still has a long way to go for box
office purists Avatar the way of water
was set to change everything the film
was expected to be the latest big screen
Mega hit a juggernaut that would pump
new life into the movie industry but
even the huge opening of James Cameron's
latest Blockbuster couldn't solve the
film industry's continuing struggles
Avatar the way of water opened to
approximately 134 million dollars
domestically and 441 million dollars
worldwide for Box Office Mojo one sign
that this was a disappointing start was
the fact that stocks for AMC
entertainment and Cinemark both dropped
on the following Monday additionally
stocks for Disney and IMAX also dropped
this doesn't necessarily spell all bad
news for Avatar the way of water as
2009's Avatar only opened to about 77
million dollars domestically for earning
more than 700 million dollars however it
does mean that the movie was not the
last minute savior the American box
office needed in 2022 so in order to do
that Avatar the way of water will need
to bring people out to the movie theater
like no other film before it according
to director James Cameron the sequel has
to break into the top five of the
all-time box office to even be
profitable meaning it potentially needs
to make two billion dollars worldwide to
get into the black Cameron told GQ you
have to be the third or fourth highest
grossing film in history that's your
threshold that's your break even there's
a drop in Share value after a less than
groundbreaking opening for Avatar the
way of water mean that movie theaters in
Disney need to worry only if they want
to breed a larger sense of Doom James
Cameron's sequel may not have brought in
over half a billion dollars during its
opening weekend but it did cross that
Mark effortlessly on December 20th 2022
thanks to International markets like
China India and Germany just like the
first avatar the sequel's success relies
on its ability to have phenomenal legs
Cameron himself has even said that the
opening weekend shouldn't dictate his
film's success the director told
Hollywood Hollywood Reporter we'll know
by the third weekend you're not going to
know by the first weekend Titanic didn't
work that way Avatar didn't work that
way however what Cameron says is far
different from what the industry expects
it would be foolish to speculate how
much Avatar the way of water will break
in but it's worth noting that 2023 will
be a big year for movie theaters so that
should quell the anxieties of
shareholders the first three months of
2023 are filled with Blockbuster
releases including the Ant-Man 3 equal
Creed 3 and John Wick chapter 4. so even
though Avatar the way of water didn't
make the biggest splash its large debut
is still a promising sign of what's to
come
foreign